so I just want to give you a little
history now you you have a heart problem
you have a calcified erotic arch right a
order and okay
remove replace the aortic arch and then
replace the aortic valve and the mitral
valve and two bad passes then I told her
I said we have some spare parts in the
back but she didn't want to do that now
I'm just kidding so you you this some of
the symptoms that you had or before you
came or what well I could I mean I
didn't breathe very well I would you
know take short breaths like today I'm
breathing much better
I don't feel every breath I take totally
and then you think it asthma yes
Hanson was I was wheezing a couple of
days ago and then you also had sleeping
problems yes really would I sleep more
than three hours at a time and then you
also climbing stairs wasn't the best
thing right I you know I could barely
make it upstairs so basically we we
worked on the adrenal acupressure points
and and just kind of tell me how you
slept well the the last night we'll say
last night I had went to sleep around
11:00 and I didn't wake up until about
6:00 and it went to the restroom and
then I went right back to sleep and woke
up at 8:30
you know I can fall asleep Wow and then
you're you're breathing better yes I'm
breathing oxygen is good and then you
feel more relaxed yes I feel a lot more
relaxed than I did at first
and it's been maybe a couple days or so
before his Friday was the first day I
got that treatment and it's Monday so
that's one two three days and then also
you even you're you're losing weight
already
I believe so we didn't but in my stomach
is flatter then before that's a good
benefit and then also you see when I was
watching her chest breathing when I was
working on her the whole chest was
trembling I mean you can just see a
trembling and because the heart was was
working so hard and everything is so
quiet now and you're not gasping for air
which is really good good so and then so
you feel more hopeful I feel that more
hopeful great hope I feel okay well
thank you very much sure